[Music]
her name's Rose McNulty I did not kill
my child we just need this woman to be
reassessed so we can move into the new
facility Rose I want to hear your story
[Music]
1942 when the war came to Belfast
out of the sky he came
what he's better has open all tell me
where he is
need to be careful side you take with us
or with the Brits who's Lane stepping
into a fairy tale
you're not from around here are you are
you placement
I'm pregnant
she was in the car with the priest you
know they're saying it's the priests
baby
what is that
[Music]
I committed my memories to my secret
Scripture
[Music]
do you not understand the power you have
over men your preachers wanted to be a
man make up your mind believe me after
the sexual behavior of an unborn
creature but I haven't told anything I
think we'll keep you here for a while
[Music]
she doesn't believe her son's death it
was economics or something message did
not kill my child do you think I killed
my baby
[Applause]
and others a sickness in people that
stops them seeing the truth
you
you